we are joined by two very very important
people to the Marvel fandom Christopher
Markus Stephen McFeely holy cow welcome
gentleman how was your convention so far
how is your say do kamikaze we did Hall
H and we didn't think anyone would want
to come to see a couple of old guys do
Hall H but also we whole H I think of as
a place where you present new things I
mean they've seen it but they're gonna
go see it again so of course in the
aftermath of Marvel Studios Avengers
endgame are you now just taking your
victory lap or you just guys just
hanging out by the pool being like man
we done and I once-a-day wonder why I'm
not doing the people are like boy you
can write your own ticket no we're
working
we've helped form a studio with the
Russo brothers bagbone expectations
writing a couple projects for that and
you know they're coming down here and
shaking their ass one of the great
things I love about that though is like
if you really do look at the track
record or the work y'all have done
together it is calm it is constant and
it's big and it's it's visually gorgeous
I got an O and we were kind of talking
about this before we went live you got
to disagree on things what is what is
the process of working together on such
big and complex storylines it we
certainly will agree a disagree occasion
occasionally more than once we've been
at it long enough to know that it's it's
getting easier to sort of put your
argument down and try it one guy's way
because if it works it's gonna work and
you're gonna have a lot of chances to
find that out and if it doesn't work
we'll circle back around
it's an incredibly long drawn-out
process like if if we had to make
something up and it would be I don't
know on stage tomorrow we'd have to come
to blows
an answer is needed but these things of
years like everything will be aired at
some point in my mind I feel like
there's just big webs of pictures and
like yarn he showed a little bit of that
today at Hall H but we couldn't show all
of it because it's just so intricate and
crazy and female take photos of it but
we make good conspiracy theory but I
don't wanna leave anything we talked
about the intricacy of your job and of
course avenging him the intricacy of all
these characters is so incredible on how
you wove them all together was there a
character if you could it's so many is
there one that you had a favor that you
were like I love writing this character
I love writing this person's voice I
love developing and finding a house and
it becomes more three-dimensional well
we got a chance in those two movies to
work with Thanos to really sort of try
to the goal was to try to make him Darth
Vader for a new generation like just
really the go-to villain and and he's a
philosopher in a way right is a very
sort of he's got a code even though it's
a twisted one so the idea to work with
him work with a really smart character
who is yeah vicious was great that's
pretty cool yeah yeah you get two
different fan oohs daños yes a little
bit fan I older older kind of more like
tome but I loved yeah the younger like
more ghastly warlord yeah what was that
like having to take the character kind
of like work backwards and find out what
he was like when he was younger he
didn't have that felt yeah it was fun I
mean you know with there's your haunted
by like oh did we make a more simplistic
version in the second one but you know
he's the half you're not getting from
the first one so it all works together
but it also reminds you of how scary he
is yeah because he doesn't have the
glove at the end of this movie and you
still have to be afraid of him and when
he walks in covered in blood you're like
that's not good that's that dude yeah
because you also get these opportunities
to see these characters at different
evolutions but also these are the
characters we know and love them
comic books you know how often are one
or your house is just full of single
issue comic books and - you know how
often do you kind of go back and the
writing process and go okay this is the
source material oh sure
you know how do we revise that it's how
do we modern I didn't grow up with
comics Chris a little bit more than me
but even then we weren't you know we
weren't the biggest collectors on the
planet yes my house now is filled with
sort of collections and statues and
stuff but Kevin Feige is really adamant
about making sure that even though we're
maturing some of it or making it real we
never lose the spirit of those early
panels in those comics so I remember
very well like he came to Atlanta one
day and said let's scrub through
starlings work right what about this can
we get Mephisto in here and and stuff
like that led to a Bini mob being a bit
of a hype man right because that's what
Mephisto was doing in those comics Oh -
singing thanasis praises and that was
they break my you see that whole scene
yeah I would pay big money to see every
mom behind Thanos on stage the man of
the hour you know wrestling match in
your brain
oh absolutely everything you know my
mind about the fans like the fans love
these characters yeah when you hear the
fans reactions and you hear the fans
what they want how does that beckon to
writing for us in terms of what fans
expect and kind of and hold on to when
they love these characters like those
core tenets well I mean you know we will
will see obviously things that are
bubbling up online when we're writing it
but it's you would get blown by the wind
every day if you responded to it but I
mean seeing the response to these things
is it's humbling because you remember
like you know because it becomes
necessarily a very grounded trying to
get this person on this piece of paper
across
paper and you forget that anybody's even
gonna see it you just like I just got to
do this and then I can eat a sandwich
you'd be great and then you hear people
cheering or crying or people thanking
you because they went with their kids
and it brought them together and it's
like like it's it's really pretty
amazing yeah and I'm sure y'all can
write basically at this point a thesis
on complicated story arcs on a
multi-person superhero teams because
that that's the incredible thing about
it is when you look at the movies
particularly Marvel Studios of Indian
game there are so many characters so
many big personalities so many
superpowers yeah how do you figure out
how to do this placement cuz I know a
lot of us particularly in that the scene
where they swear she goes she's not
alone and like all the women come
together like that moment was so key and
so pinnacle but it didn't seem like it
was weird that this this power came in
like you had Valkyrie go into the air
like this what was like right
hey Valerie I'm gonna go into the flame
kind of how do you keep those things
I mean rate yeah it's not easy and I you
know once it gets to actual fighting
there are you know extremely talented
people who who can negotiate that better
than we can I mean it always comes down
to character for us if we can come down
if we can come to a character reason why
you can get those people together that
doesn't knock you out of the story then
we'll do it and then you can figure out
how the dynamic works there but there
are times where I've forgotten what
people can do and you write a really
good fight scene and then you remember
like oh they don't do that or like oh
you could have just pulled down some
lightning and that's right he probably
can really finish that a lot is that
we're we're trying to find particularly
in a movie with so many people notes for
each person right like moments it's not
going to be the Mantis movie but you can
probably remember three or four good
moments for mantis in infinity war right
so that's that's our challenge is to
give everyone there
are there moments 10 minutes of fame
yeah yeah well you gentlemen have way
more than 15 minutes you have a whole
lifetime of fame and I want to say as
two fans thank you for that incredible
story and he'll be the most on the ride
you took us on everyone
Chris Steve thank you for joining us